so here we go here's my little scenario
I have a sprint it's attached to the
ceiling and on the end of the spring
which is why it's stretched out there is
a weight attached okay
w-4 weight now this weight is stretching
out the spring and at the moment it's
not going anywhere okay so this is where
it's at rest if you like it's not moving
so I'm going to call this point x equals
0 I'm just gonna define remember with
these motion questions we can define x
equals 0 wherever like right on the beam
and I don't know how long the spring is
the place where it is right now seems
like as good a definition is it okay
all right now I'm gonna give you three
questions to do in this and you'll see
how relates two functions of
displacement um what we're gonna do with
the with the weight is lifted up two
meters okay so the weight is lifted two
meters let's just assume you know one
dimensional movement so two meters
directly involved x equals zero okay and
then it is released okay so you can see
the motion of this object is obviously
gonna be governed by gravity also you
know this spring and it's elasticity and
that kind of thing
so let's just assume okay now it's
movement after that point is defined as
its acceleration being minus 4x minus 4x
so you can see it's about the force
acting upon this weight okay is
depending on okay how far are you from
where you started take minus 4x right so
it's in terms of your distance from x
equals zero so faster guys
so here my three questions okay let's
get can we get velocity as a function of
displacement
first velocity secondly can we show sure
that this weight is going to be
stationary four meters below where we
dropped it
okay so you can work out the x value for
that which is not too difficult
lastly can we work out the maximum speed
note that it's speed not velocity what
is that maximum speed and where does it
occur now you can see I mean just
because of the way that this is all
phrased right velocity is a function of
X sure than stationary at this place
sure that we'll find the speed and where
it happens so it's all the the question
of not when life is no there's no time
for this at all in this system but I
mean there is but we're not interested
in okay we're just interested about
positions so how do we go about solving
this well we're gonna use this result
okay let's just assume we just proved it
in Part A and this is actually puppy CD
right so what you're gonna do is take
your acceleration function and notice
that it's in terms of X not in terms of
team okay so hey this is first part is
minus 4x right therefore you take your
result this one yeah okay the derivative
with respect to X of half v square okay
occasionally you'll see it as written
with that v squared on to up the top
okay I mean you can see it's the same
thing it's just wherever you put the
actual function your different shape
that's minus 4x okay now before I go any
further you can see it wouldn't have
done much good to get this in terms of T
because when you look at you right hand
side it's not in terms of T so you can't
integrate with respect to T because what
you saw is all you're gonna get out of
it but at this point left hand side in
terms x right hand x in terms of X so
I'm gonna integrate so I'm gonna get 1/2
B squared is equal to the integral of
minus 4 X with respect to X
okay so this is the Entebbe here has
moved over to the other side so minus 4x
you do great what do you get good now
this is an indefinite integral right
we're going to use our initial
conditions in a second to actually work
out but instead of writing my constant
is plus C I'm gonna write it as C on to
okay
remember the clusters anything you like
right you've seen about 30 seconds why
wrote co2 rather than just plain old C
now I want to work out what that C is
what the constant is okay so you can see
here just to make things a little bit
neater because I know what initial
velocity is it's implied in the way that
I read the question I'm gonna get V
squared I'm a multiply through by two to
get rid of half minus 4x squared plus C
right now if I want to solve for C I
might as well have it not a fraction
like ybm you know double it up it's just
simpler that way okay so what additional
conditions do we know about this I
didn't tell you that at rest it was an X
equal zero but then we did something to
it namely we lifted it to meters okay
and I had it in my hand or whatever was
holding okay
so therefore I want to know the
relationship between particular velocity
and a particular displacement right so
I'd say at right so now this is not
gonna be time equals zero it's going to
be what's my what's my starting what's
the first thing we don't x equals two
right I'm directly above so at x equals
two right it's not moving I haven't
released it yet
okay so that's my velocity at that place
I actually have been saying initial
which is a bit naughty of me because it
really doesn't have to do with what you
start it's about where you are okay but
it's just in the way we talk and say
okay this is where I begin so now I just
substitute into actually a value of a
constant right so Y zero equals -4 times
or + C so there's my constant okay so
this answers here a I'm actually it's a
bit sneaky we're going to get to what
happens later when we need to get rid of
the squared okay but I'm gonna leave it
out
there's my interface B squared is minus
4x squared plus 16 okay getting rid of
the up the square taking the square root
is a bit tricky we'll deal with that
later today I hope every other time all
right now next question show that this
weight is stationary four meters below
graph is drawn and that's not too hard
four meters below where those jobs
because drop from x equals two right
so for bidders below that is x equals -2
right so at x equals -2 V squared will
be it's just a straight substitution
yeah so I'm gonna have minus 4 times
minus 2 squared plus 16 which is minus
16 and there's actually what I was asked
to show that is substation right so I
would say at this point as required
that's the result of that okay so now
let's finish it off what is the max of
speedom where now I know when you hear
the word maximum you sort of like like
Pavlov's dog we're trained you to think
okay that's mean differentiate find a
stationary point that kind of thing but
I want you to look carefully at the
equation of for what's that you'll
actually velocity squared okay if I try
to work out okay now you can
differentiate it's fine but there's a
much simpler approach if I kind of work
out an action speed what's it going to
be how would you go out thinking about
it if V squared is
you order around maybe that'll make you
a little pair if that's like a lot see
function C squared function where is the
maximum when now see this right x
squared
obviously x squared is a it's gonna be
positive or the smallest it could be in
a zero okay so I'm sorry it's sixteen
and then I subtract whatever this is
okay so as I get further away this thing
is getting be done right so sixteen
minutes now is going to be less and less
and less right so what actually what is
for this thing to be as small as
possible and the smallest it can be is
zero right because x squared is always
gonna be that so therefore maximum
velocity okay what's it going to equal
two
it'll be a B squared equals sixteen
minus 0 right okay now we were asked us
to speed right that means come in
irrespective of direction
so basically they're right maximum speed
therefore is four meters per second
because I'm not interested by this point
down I'm just interested in my bosses
now where does it happened
well we actually saw I've already
answered that right it's when 4x squared
is equal to 0 which implies X is equal
to Y right this occurs actually at that
point of rest now does that actually
make sense to you right it goes fastest
as a pulse as that point because I'm
after that it's gonna start slowing down
to come back towards that of that
resting point so yeah there's there's
water pressures of this by the way I
will quickly tell you why would we want
to avoid that I am gonna have to get if
I want to be on the x2 what kind of
stationary point I'm gonna have to do
this right which admittedly ok you guys
can't do but it's just a mess
especially when there's such a simple
approach to actually get the answer ok
so that's why think about your equations
and what they mean and what beats me to
solve on that to be a situation without
to try to avoid